this is what we are going to learn in
this video for a 2d image like this
after flattening it into a 1d vector we
are going to fit it into a model to
classify the image into one of the
single-digit numbers ranging from 0 to 9
let's just call this model Network for
now this simple network has only two
layers the input size is 6 times 6 which
is 36 in total the output size is 10 10
is the number of classes we have each
connection between the input layer and a
pool layer is a model parameter in this
case we have 360 parameters now let's
look at how to do image classification
with this model assuming the model
parameters are already optimized the
first step is to perform a linear
weighted sum of the input with the model
weights the output from this step is D
which is just a 1 by 10 vector which
stores the scores for each output class
then we can feed these scores to a
softmax function softmax function will
normalize the input vector into the
range from 0 to 1 which can now be
interpreted as the probability for each
class in this case we have the highest
probability for the digit 7 so the model
will predict the input image as 7 this
is almost all the mass and concept you
need to know let's start the fun part
here I will work you through the code
about how to import the dataset define
the model train the model and the
evaluates the model in a way you have
never seen before let's first have a
look at the libraries we are using pet
or numpy and as killin' they are all
very famous libraries commonly used in
both research and industry
the first step is to import the data set
touch vision from Pat touch allows us to
import and download the Minister dataset
directly from its API the Minister
deficits here is one of the most common
data sets used for image classification
it is a data set of handwritten digits
which contains sixty Sultan's training
images and ten thousands testing images
then we use data loader to load the data
into an iterator during this process we
randomly shuffle the data set and split
into the data sets into batches
shuffling the data set serves the
purpose of producing variants and making
sure the models room is general and over
faithless for example you need to
shuffle your data set if it is sorted by
your class here for each batch there are
four images you need this line of code
will help us to get one batch of images
and let's have a closer look at one of
the images the image has 28 times 28
pixels which is 784 in total each pixel
holds an Amber range from 0 to 1 that
represents the grayscale values of the
corresponding pixels now it is the time
to define the model this line of the
code will help us to define the model
structure it is a simple two layer
Network structure improve dimension is
28 times 28 which is 784 in total and
the output dimension is 10 0 is a
connection between each pair of input
and output and each connection here
represents a model parameter in the
forward function we define how the model
is going to be run from input to output
first we need to reshape the 2d image
into 1d so the total number of input
here is 784 which matches the network
input and the next step is to calculate
the weighted sum of the input acts with
the model parameter W finally we can
return the output
so that's an introduction and how do we
import it and define the model of our
image a classification task here I will
also provide the source code with collab
notebook for this video in the
description in the next video I'm going
to talk about how to train and evaluate
this model don't forget to subscribe to
us and brain the notification valve and
stay tuned